foreign
[Music]
numbers of families in Britain
struggling to pay for food
and as millions of people face
starvation in Africa we have a special
report on drought-beating crops and the
world leaders announced the next climate
change Summit cop 27 was to be held in
Africa in Egypt I was glad because they
need to listen up
[Music]
hi there so here's some shocking info we
found right now there are four million
British children whose parents are
struggling to pay the bills and buy food
and each month this year those numbers
have been rising to that figure but why
Skyler well it's down to many issues but
basically everything's getting more
expensive while the money our parents
are earning isn't always going up you
might have heard on the news reporters
talking about the cost of living crisis
and we've been looking into what that
actually means
so the covid pandemic meant that a lot
of things weren't being made so they
were in short supply and cost more
the war in Ukraine means that our food's
getting pricey because we used to get a
lot of our ingredients from there
there's been a growing demand for gas
and oil that we use for our cars Central
Heating and to generate electricity and
because there's just not enough of it
the prices have been increasing
the food Foundation a charity that
supports struggling families asked a
group of young people to share their
unique ways of appealing for more help
by the government
so they decided to write and record a
poem
So today we're creating a spoken word
but we're basically creating poetry to
do with free School meals and why free
School meals are important and they
should be extended to everyone at the
start of the day we just wrote the words
preschool meal on a paper and we just
threw words at it so like what comes in
our mind what will happen if there are a
few schools meals and all those just
like random words it's from different
different perspectives of people who are
affected by Fresco meals and like with
six young people and we've chosen
different perspectives and written our
own section and brought it all together
I see potential and I see so much in my
classroom of countless hungry children
as a parent I want to bring the world
and put her on my child's feet feet that
deserve more I am the politician I am
the Hope or am I the dark skinny Knights
that take away a Shining Light
have you ever experienced food
insecurity or maybe you've noticed like
a friend or someone at school who's been
experiencing that so my friends they
have and like it makes me feel like
guilty for not providing anything for
them or like not being able to do
anything for them they just feel left on
like they're not really engaged and like
they're not really happy with life for
example and like you can see on their
faces how down they're feeling yeah and
like that's like something that I
normally should have people through so
I've seen many people at school who have
who have preschool meals and maybe some
who actually aren't eligible for it
either so they can't actually afford to
buy lunch for themselves to buy enough
lunch the poem giving voices to all
people affected by the rising costs of
food has now been sent to the prime
minister
I can't concentrate I can't sleep well I
can't even survive let alone thrive
[Music]
there's even bigger issues issues in
some parts of Africa hear me out covert
and conflict have led to a shortage of
food but it's climate change that's the
biggest issue drought has killed off
crops millions of people in Ethiopia
Somalia and parts of Kenya have little
or no access to food and water many are
now experiencing starvation but there is
hope isn't there jariah almost 200
countries who are responsible for
producing the gases that led to global
warming have agreed to give money to
Nations worst hit by climate change the
agreement was made at The cop27 Summit
in Egypt
the money could be used to build flood
defenses and in Africa there is hope
that it could help farmers produce crops
to survive a drought here's eliane to
explain more she's Kenya's youngest
Environmental campaigner
I have planted over 1 million trees
across Africa and just near my home in
the city of Nairobi Kenya with
permission of course
here I organize events to get lots of
people to buy seeds and plant trees
they help soak up climate changing gases
like carbon dioxide produced by cars and
power stations
when the world leaders announced the
next climate change Summit cop 27 was to
be held in Africa in Egypt I was glad
because they need to listen up
[Music]
this is what it's like in East and
Northern Kenya
just a few hours drive from my city
it used to be green and healthy land
producing food for those who lived there
but look at it now
the land is dry
the crops are failing
people are starving here
[Music]
Kenya is experiencing its worst job in
40 years
more than 7 million people in the north
and east are without food are access to
water
Millions more in neighboring countries
Africa is among the smallest producers
of carbon dioxide
yet it is becoming the biggest victim of
climate change
lots of Charities are trying their best
to save lives
hey Tiffany I just want to know how bad
is it out there where you are the
epidemic of malnutrition in this part of
Kenya has reached severe levels every
day we see over 200 people for
life-saving interventions for Hunger
response unless they put scarcity in
these areas improves lives will most
certainly be lost
foreign
[Music]
but here there is hope
just a few years ago parts of this
region had become so dry it had been
declared a semi-dessert but now look at
it when Farmers here saw how climate
change was destroying their fertile land
they took action before it was too late
I discovered that farmers in the west
have avoided a famine they are learning
about a new way to grow crops and to
evolved my favorite weapon to be climate
change trees
[Music]
okay this one maze Charities are
teaching young Farmers like Naman that
trees not only save dry and damaged soil
but also protect their crops from
drought so I can show you have some
purpose over there yes these ones fruits
you can eat either you like you can sell
but before Naman could grow his crops he
needed trees lots of them the issue is
they had all been chopped down
traditionally farmer destroy forests to
create Fields so where did all these
trees come from
it was discovered that if a stump of a
tree had sheets like this you could
bring the tree and the soil back to life
but once the trees are established the
roots draw up water very deep
underground and hold rain water around
its roots
tree roots also attract food for the
crops minerals and organic material
known as nutrients
and the cheese act like a canopy
protecting the crops from the wind and
the burning Sun
about this method of farming at school
when he was 12. he gave it a go with no
income the man needed to do something to
save the family
how did it feel when you got your first
ever cup I feel excited because the
demand of products was very high
three years on the man and his family
are producing enough crops to feed
themselves and others and he is passing
on his knowledge to the next generation
of young farmers
[Music]
Charities have trained more than a
hundred thousand young Farmers had to
bring their Farms back to life
in other parts of Africa the land is
lost it is too late but here there is
real hope
I want Africa to help others what I
found here is answers not problems
thanks elianne and for more amazing
climate change beating ideas check out
the sky kids documentary cop 27 six ways
to save our planet available right now
on sky kids and Via our webpage
first.news FYI
coming up Brady meets the famous faces
behind the voices of my father's dragon
are you for real of course I'm real that
was made up can I do this
what do you think
is this tree really hanging in the
balance
nope it's an illusion created by street
artist Huang Yao who is going viral with
his 3D artwork across China
[Music]
the World Cup host Qatar had been
criticized over their strict laws which
include a ban on same-sex relationships
but you will have noticed that football
can be much more than just a game some
plays and fans States the chance to
highlight issues in our world as it
comes together others including FIFA
which organizes the World Cup so we
should just focus on football
so so many countries including England
were going to wear the one love Iron Man
The Wonder of armband means love and
respect regardless of your religion race
or even gender but on Monday morning
just a few hours before the Iran vs
England match FIFA released a statement
saying that no countries were allowed to
wear the one love armband and if he did
a play would get booked before the match
or even sent off that's so scary because
they didn't even know what the penalties
could be I mean it could be a yellow
card you know banned from playing
whatever it was it was such a risk
because they just don't know what could
happen before their match with England
Iran's team refused to sing their
national anthem yeah what was going on
there well to support all the protests
that are going back on in their home
country with girls protesting for equal
rights I mean they've not been wearing
their headscarves and they've been
getting punished for that and people
have even died I mean it's such a brave
thing for them to do because they've
been heavy Crackdown on protesters so
when they do get back home they get
really punished for what they've done
wow on a brighter note let me tell you
about this story during England's game
with Iran this is brilliant he looks
amazing Manchester City player Jack
grealish met up with superfan Finley
Fisher who was cerebral palsy Finley
wrote to grealish when he learned that
the player's sister Holly also has
cerebral palsy during the meeting Jack
grealish made this promise
yeah all right I'll do that for you all
right I promise but remember I've got a
score though next time next time of
school yeah all right then true to his
word he did the dance after scoring the
sixth goal in England 6-2 win against
Iran at the World Cup
we have another story for you but is it
fake or fact
[Music]
is this comedian really shred 10 000
pounds
Joe Lysette threatened to destroy the
money in protest if the former England
player David Beckham didn't resign from
his role promoting qatar's World Cup
when Beckham didn't respond the comedian
released this video
but it's fake he later revealed he did
not shed real money and instead he
donated 10 000 pounds to charity
I would never destroy real money I would
never be so irresponsible
[Music]
loads of new films are due out as we
approach Christmas yeah Braden has met
the famous faces behind the voices of my
father's dragon
the times got hard Elmer
and he was a child like any other
struggling to cope after a move to the
city with his mother Elma runs away in
search of a wild Island and a young
dragon who waits to be rescued
my name is Elmer my name is Boris not as
cool but it goes with my face
together they form a rocky relationship
trying to outwit ferocious beasts in
order to save the island from Doom
there must be a way to figure it out
early in the film we see that Elm was
trying to hide a cat inside the
apartment even though he's not really
allowed to is it now let's flip this and
say you have to hide a dragon right a
muscle Trucking where are we hiding the
dragon I have an idea there's no way
you're going to be able to fit like a
dragon in a closet what you have to do
is hide the dragon in plain sight and
worse could be the sofa oh there we go
now we're getting an audition also early
in the film we see that Elmer's mother's
struggling a little bit financially now
are there any messages that you think
young people should take away from this
film when you're young it's hard to
really register when when your family is
struggling uh and it's sometimes you
grow up in that in that environment and
you start to learn as you get older that
a lot of times life is really unfair and
it hurts and it stings and it's
especially hurts to see your parents go
through something like that the way to
get through these situations is through
the people in your life I think an
important part about this movie is how
Elmer throughout the movie he's kind of
being a bit more selfish but in the end
he decides that he needs to do the right
thing and you know let Boris be his own
dragon but what is the biggest
difference
like in a random recording booth and
that recording booth kind of became our
home what's the matter you got a hugger
two cool for public displays of
affection there's so much Freedom going
into it I remember us doing Irish Jigs
and I was just getting to run around and
enjoy this like kind of playroom that we
had created this really was my lucky day
and tomorrow's gonna be even luckier
[Music]
well that wasn't that Christmassy but I
do love Christmas films yeah what'd you
love about Christmas films it's just so
exciting they get you in the festive
Spirit they're great give me brownies
popcorn I'm all good I love all
Christmas films yeah don't we all so
that's all the info we have this week
but if you have a story and want to
report an FYI get in touch via our
webpage yeah there's details there on
how your teachers can set up FYI news
clubs so you can get more involved see
you next time bye
foreign